uh next up we've got rachel in little
rock arkansas
rachel how can we help you hi
so i am 19 years old okay
and i moved out of my parents house
officially
in september and i have a full-time job
i tried the college life and decided i
wasn't going to waste money if i didn't
have a plan
okay um so i have no debt my car is paid
for i paid for my car
um i haven't had any type of credit card
um but i'm trying to make a decision of
if i need to
buy a newer car first for
stability's sake okay or if i should get
a house and stuff
renting because my car is 2008.
okay 2008 how many miles are on it
uh 151. 151
what kind of car did you say it was
again rachel
it's a subaru impreza okay gotcha you
have to laugh don't make fun of your car
it can hear you yeah
okay don't you don't want your car to
get upset so be nice
here okay rachel how much money do you
have in your bank account right now
um so i have my 1 000 emergency fund and
then
um on a separate thing
i have a i think 2500.
when you say a separate tax return
for 2500 because i didn't get a stimulus
check when they came out since i looked
at my parents house so they're giving me
those as well
so when you say a separate thing are you
talking about a separate bank account or
do you have this invested like one of
those
just want to make sure it's not
investing one of those little apps that
people are saying that we're saving up
for so you got 3 500
saved up what are you making annually
right now
um annually 28 000 before tax
28 000 before tax all right correct
all right so i'm gonna give you
something you may not like that's
perfect okay cool
great so here's the thing here's the
thing you're doing great
i want to say this right now you're 19
years old you have no debt
uh you got 3 500 in your savings account
uh so let me go
let's talk about the car i think that
you the car is great you have 150 000
miles on it
it's a reliable car i'm going to tell
you just keep
up with the maintenance if you take care
of the car
getting it properly maintained as far as
oil changes tire rotations making your
fluids are good
as long as you stick to that that car
will last you
to about 200 220 000 miles you know
then from there on the flip side i want
you to really start getting don't worry
about a house right now
all right i want you to skip over to
baby step number three and i need you to
set aside three to six months of your
expenses
then while you're doing that i want you
to go connect with our good friend ken
coleman
because we need to get your income up
you're at 28 000
a year right now which is okay i'm i'm
okay with that at your
age but we need to get you up to right
around 50 000
then we can start talking about
purchasing a home
but once you do get your three to six
months of expenses
i don't have a problem just going over
to 3b start saving a little bit
but what i really want you to do is get
your your shovel a little bit bigger
and ken coleman if you go to
kencoleman.com
and listen to his content he'll teach
you how to get into that career space
and figure out how to really do that but
that's what i really want you to focus
on at 19
getting your income up getting a fully
funded emergency fund
but i love it i expect to see you in the
house by 22
by 21 22 if you really do these things
over the next two years
but i think you're in a perfect place my
little dream is to have a tiny house so
the house i want would be like
twenty to forty thousand dollars it
wouldn't even wait hold on rachel what
do you mean a tiny house
yeah that's popular how big are they
they're tiny
what really they're like
hold on hey yo hush what how how many
square feet
like 300. listen man it's popular within
this younger generation
and she can pull it it's about my size
i'm living that minimalist life y'all
hey there's nothing wrong with that
listen don't you let the world try to
tell you what you need to do it's good
that you have your own dreams
uh you know but at the same time i think
you move at the
at the speed of cash like anthony was
telling you and you having that down
payment uh is big
here's another thing this subaru which
you need to go out there and give it a
hug
and tell it you're sorry because she was
making fun of it that might be able to
go 200 250 000 more miles
but here's the reality it doesn't have
to be miles that you put on it
you can move at the speed of cash and so
you thinking of side hustles
you being intentional you could come up
with money to replace that car sooner
than later
but don't don't get caught up in it the
car's job is to get you from point a to
point b
it's not to try to impress people and
when people get that confused that's
where they end up
overspending that's where i did my
stupid
uh and so you want to be smart and avoid
car payments absolutely like the plague
uh it's that important thank you for
your call
i love it you know what hogan i want to
say this on the show i want to learn
more about this mini house so if you're
listening right now
um i want you to dm me at anthony o'neil
go to anthony knows instagram and if
you're living in a mini house and you're
a millennial
i'm going to bring you onto my and i
want to talk about this i want to know i
want to know i want to learn more about
it i want to come let me come on there
with you yeah let's do it because
because is it like can you
do you just pick it up bro it's smaller
than
this and i'm like okay i purchased house
to resale right so i want to learn more
about it so if you
have one no don't don't hit me up if you
thinking about one i want to know if you
have one
hit me up on my dm i'm gonna bring you
on to the show and hold on i'm gonna
make sure you on the show too let's talk
about it because if it's 300 square feet
you can't get all your shoes in there
i'm going to tell you right now
because i know i can't get mine in there
so but yeah i'd love to know more about
it i don't know if anybody that's living
in one
and i've got a couple of friends that
work at hgtv and they do some stuff so
we need to get them
all right that's what dmao tell them
your tell them your dm
how'd they do it go to instagram hit me
up anthony o'neil
okay and you'll see my information there
dm me uh and i promise you we're gonna
make this into a show yeah we'll find
out more we're not gonna go crazy but we
want to learn yeah
i mean we may have to go out and and go
to one of these
let's do this
on the road yes we are going to check
out this tiny house situation
and we're going to find out how they
really work can you imagine you walking
into what okay well we have to get that
on camera
this is going to be fun what if we spent
the night in one oh no i ain't doing
that bro
that's exactly what we're gonna do we're
gonna do an overnight camping trip
i love it